That gonna fit everyone?
Yeah, easily. Twelve customers total.
How do they turn a profit?
$1,250 a head, that's how.
What are we eating, a Rolex?
It's one of his classics.
You have to try the mouthfeel
of the mignonette.
Please don't say mouthfeel.
Tonight will be madness.
Welcome.
We'll endeavor to make your evening
as pleasant as possible.
Welcome to Hawthorn.
Here, we are family.
Yes, Chef!
We harvest. We ferment. We gel.
-They gel?
-We gel.
He's not just a chef. He's a storyteller.
The game is trying to guess
what the overarching theme
of the entire meal is gonna be.
You won't know until the end.
-Who are you?
-I am Margot.
Why do you care?
I have to know if you're with us,
or with them.
This menu...
The pictures, they're of us.
This guest list...
-How did they get these?
-It's not good.
This entire evening...
-Jesus Christ!
-This is just theater, it's stagecraft!
We're leaving, now.
...has been painstakingly planned.
This is real, isn't it?
What the hell is going on?
We now offer you a 45 second head start.
Okay, 45 seconds starts now.
This is what you're paying for.
Get out of my way.
It's all part of the menu.
-It's okay.
-No, we're gonna die tonight.
-Yes, we are.
-Yeah.
Happy birthday to you!
You told them it was my birthday?
Seemed funny about three hours ago.